okay here we have Rowan and Rowan really
handsome he actually has movie star
looks but he has a very athletic body
and one that you wouldn't think would
match up with a suit I think of all the
guys that we did in project upgrade he
has the body that most guys have which
is like a little bit thick everywhere a
little bit stocky through the through
the torso and also a little bit thicker
in the thighs and I think that's one of
the number one questions we get is like
if I have bigger legs from playing
sports how do I fit into these slim
suits well now we're going to tell you
so we put him in a Ralph Lauren
pinstripe suit you might say why a
pinstripe suit for a guy who's only six
foot tall and that's precisely why I
love the stripes on him the stripes
give him some height but it also ties
into what his occupation is he's in
sales and I think a pinstripe suit for
me really says like I'm going to sell
you something great I'm going to stand
behind what I'm selling you so the
pinstripes will definitely make him
longer make him a leaner and also hide
the fact that maybe his legs are a
little bit bigger and out of proportion
with the rest of his body and still give
him that really slimming effect because
from playing sports for so many years he
does have a good physique it's just not
necessarily good too easy for a suit
unless you buy the right suit so Ralph
Lauren is famous for putting a shape
into the suit there's a lot of
interfacing and shoulder padding and a
lot of a lot of interior bells and
whistles to give you a shape and that's
what we did so again if you've got a
little bit of those thick athletic
features you want to think about trying
a pinstripe that's definitely going to
a vertical line to the way you dress do
you want to try wearing something that
has a little bit more of a shoulder you
want to try to go for something that is
slimming the legs but not too tight and
then you want to try to take something
as conservative with pinstripe suit and
then have a little bit fun with it